on the surface you look like someone who
just kind of plays by the rules you're
kind of a nice girl from next door who's
silly and funny but
i don't think everybody would probably
know that
you
like so many people right now i've been
living my life
online been working from home online
meetings
i talked to my friends through google
hangouts and it got me thinking
how much can a private investigator find
out about you
if they had 60 minutes if someone wanted
to
stalk me or i don't know bring me down
in an expose
how easy would it be for them to do that
i really
don't know what's out there there could
be some pretty embarrassing stuff
some stuff that i've definitely blacked
out
now's the time to find out if i've got
like way too much information out there
so
i can hopefully fix it so i called
elizabeth south
private investigator and put her on the
case
hello hi elizabeth this is sarah from
buzzfeed
hi sarah how are you doing how are you
thank you for taking the call
you're looking up background seeing what
i can find on
one of the steps that i'm going to give
you information right and that that
staff member is actually going to be me
what do you need to start the search
your first and last name
have you ever found like a person that
has a second family
or anything like that oh yeah oh that is
that common more common than i've been
yeah i dated them
oh oh god that woman on accident without
knowing it like three times yeah
and i ended up dating a lot of wall
street guys with one or two other
families had no idea
then i got into pi oh that was your
inspiration yeah
so how much time do you need three to
four hours we'll get quite a bit
information on you
all right thank you take care pleasure
look forward to it
bye bye bye elizabeth says before you
hire a private investigator you should
always research them so
i'm going to investigate her okay kay
and associates
okay she's not in a flight company so i
must have spelled it wrong
all right so this is where she works
kane associates
you should see if how long they're
licensed okay so
we're gonna do a search here license
type
lamp adjuster i didn't know that that
was a thing
up will you look at that 1992
september 16 1992 issuance date okay
when i'm going through
my research and i'm looking up miss
sarah burton
i mean obviously you know we have
databases where
we get a lot of our information from and
we cross-reference that however
i don't think people realize how much
information you can actually get off
social media
really everything i know almost
everything about you now
elizabeth south google which one are you
no that can't be her is that her i had
to stop
looking up things about elizabeth
because it felt
weird but um she is legit
so now i'm legitimately scared to find
out what she
finds out about me i guess i'll just
wait
what was most interesting was when i had
a call with a former
roommate i wonder if her family knows
about this
i was informed that she
[Music]
hello hi how are you good how are you
so there probably wasn't that much on me
right
well i mean i don't know we consider
very much i got a lot of info on you oh
no
okay all right all right all right well
i guess we should just
dive in yeah i did find out something
that probably is not on your social
media profile i mean here's the thing
okay most most people are like you like
you're gonna have
facebook you really need to make it
private especially if you have friends
or you're gonna be posting any private
information because
that really tells people where they can
find you most people
don't realize how much information they
input into the app
that you can still be located with even
for you i recommend having
private accounts and then public
accounts like i have a number of
celebrity friends but
they have a separate account under a
name that's not connected to them they
do not
don't connect your phone number to it i
can find you like that okay
connect your regular email to it i mean
there's i can't give away too many
secrets but
i have conversations with my friends
like if anyone ever calls you
you hit me up first you never trust
anybody if i would have wanted to find
loads of information on you very easy to
do when you say
loads of information what do you mean i
mean not only all of your friends back
to high school who is connected to you
what you are doing your interest your
job history your hobbies
so the stuff that is up there now in the
past
even if i go and change privacy settings
or i delete them
that doesn't necessarily mean it's gone
from the internet that's what you're
saying
that's exactly what i'm saying did you
find anything
bad about me was there anything that you
would recommend that i
take offline i mean so if you're really
like if you're one of these
i would say conservative religious
people they might they may find it
sinister
i found it super entertaining and i
decided we could be friends
okay i found out for your birthday
that you wanted to have a seance and
there was an exorcism part two
yeah to try to exercise my demons
did it work um i guess so because my
record's pretty clean right
as you probably know i don't have like
an arrest record or anything
so i feel like i don't have that much
is there anything else that you found
most people
maybe wouldn't realize you could find so
easily i know i have
your phone numbers you know linked to
you i have all of your
past addresses i have you listed from
march 2011 to october 2012
that's completely accurate i can give
you five others
no i don't need to i you go move on move
on your
your social security is
this is just on a flat across the board
what we get from our databases
okay okay tell how you vote how you're
registered to vote
i see all your family members their age
their dates of birth
all of your neighbors now this is going
to probably freak you out a little bit
um okay so not only do i all your
possible neighbors i can see all of your
possible
neighbors their social security their
date of birth their age
and all addresses associated with them
as well as getting their phone numbers
so if i wanted to interview literally
anyone you've ever been
near i could do it wow yeah please don't
call
my neighbor from 2012. thank you well
that's too late
yeah i did talk to one of your neighbors
i have conversations with my friends
like if anyone ever calls you
you hit me up first you never trust
anybody
really nice very sweet on the surface
you look like someone who just kind of
plays by the rules you're comedic you're
kind of a nice girlfriend next door
who's silly and funny but
i don't think everybody would probably
know that
you donated eggs wasn't that around 2012
something like that that was
i did that right after college to pay
off some of my debt but
like very few people know that
i do how everyone who watches this video
is probably gonna know
i mean it's it's fine it's okay i i
don't feel bad about it it's just one of
those like
things that i did in the past if i would
have
wanted to go deeper into that and to
find what
happened it's a very good possibility we
could have gotten information
so i'm not saying that sometime in the
future you know 10 15 years from now
that i might not get a call from
somebody who
you may end up being their birth mother
and we can track that back i selected a
program where i
did it anonymously so i thought there's
always a way to find that answer
that's all i know i do realize with the
internet and
obviously with all these dna testing
gonna pop up yeah because you didn't
think back in 2012 that this would
happen like
when me and my partner got together i
was like before we get married we're
doing an
ancestry thing i'm gonna make sure you
don't have any love children that i
don't know about
because i might not stay with you if i
find that what can i do now
to try to make myself
more secure if it's a place you
frequently go
that people could just walk in there and
see you and you don't want to be family
this is our sunday brunch place i'm like
well if you want to be found fine
but most girls i know are on dating apps
and most dating apps
actually all dating apps have a lot of
creeps on them if
you are on a dating profile do not use
pictures that you put on your other
social media profiles
because okay because they'll match them
up what i recommend to absolutely
everybody
don't autofill credit cards never put
that computer on a public wi-fi
okay even if you're a starbucks you open
up your computer
and it's going to automatically connect
and you do have professional hackers
where they will hang out near coffee
shops or places where there's free wi-fi
and it's real easy to get on your wi-fi
and
go through all of your information so do
i need to have a discussion with uh
my friends about answering phone calls
yes absolutely okay all right thank you
thank you soon they goodbye
see you later bye bye
so what did i learn pretty clean
online record not too much out there
she was able to contact my old roommates
and get them to talk
she was able to find out i donated my
eggs
which is wild because that is something
i did
years ago like if i have kids they're
eight years old and they could find me
i'm either from like dna tests or
obviously hiring a private investigator
so i guess i just need to know that will
happen and be at peace with it because
you can't really change what you did in
the past just try to protect
your present and be smart now or i don't
know
witness protection maybe all right so
stay safe out there i gotta get to work
on making some
private and public social media accounts
you don't want a stalker so i'm cleaning
my socials
bye
you